hello everyone and welcome back everyone
and especially congratulations to
everyone who came to this video by
clicking on the first link in the
description in the previous video as
this is not the Armageddon game between
Magnus cross and each monitor Anand they
drew their classical game in the first
round of the OtterBox norway
championship so now Carson gets 10
minutes on the clock
Anand get seven minutes but to win on
our leader has to you know just draw the
game or or win the game he can't lose
and Carson has to win the game that's
how Armageddon works so without further
ado let's just check it out in this game
Carson doesn't go for the Queens gambit
declined but rather he tries it with c4
the English opening and Anand replies
with E 5 with Knight to c3 and now comes
Bishop to b4 we have nice the d5 now
attacking the bishop forcing it to move
back and Bishop to e7 by Anand and now
d4 this is a sort of a new line that's
being tested now
it captures on d4 Queen captures on d4
and mount Knight to f6 so they really
have to you know be fast especially on
this he only has 7 minutes on the clock
we have Knight captures on e7 by
crossing Queen captures and now Bishop
to g5 and it's so it's a system that
across since the second in the watch's
champions you measure between across and
Caruana Daniel dubov plays so it's very
interesting maybe maybe they've even
worked on it together Knight to c6
pushing the Queen back Queen to c3 and
now comes Knight to e5 and i centralized
square for the knight also if the knight
comes to f3 Anand will have the option
of just exchanging it which Crossland
does we have Knight to f3 and it's
interesting that in this position
unknown movies f3 and the g3 is a known
game
Donald oversees elders where g3 was
played and the duo was able to win this
game but here Knight to f3 is a new move
by Carson which I'm sure did not come as
a pleasant surprise Ronon but he Anand
did not spend any time here so problem
maybe he was even prepared I know I
haven't seen the interview after the
game if any of you have you know do
share in the comments with d6 defending
the knight and now III by Carson saying
okay if you want to trade here I'm just
gonna trade back with the Jeep on and
I'm
happy with this position maybe I'm gonna
even Castle queenside as I do have to go
for a win here we have h6 pushing the
Batchelor back bush up to each four and
now even g5 by Anand and here before
retreating Carlsen decides to play
tonight captures on e5 which allows
Anand a very nice tactic but under
missed it it's not not a deadly tactic
or anything it just allows honest to
exchange everything and go to a you know
perfectly equal endgame which which
would be very favorable to him as it is
an Armageddon and he has to draw this so
here Anand had to go for Knight to e4
attacking the Queen and then Carson will
go Knight to c6 opening up an attack
against the rook here but then you just
trade everything Knight captures Knight
captures here you would go King captures
on e7 and now push up to g3
as you don't want to lose your dark
square Bishop Knight goes here and now
it's a like I said it's a equal position
why does have the bishop pair for the
moment but you know Anand will be able
to eliminate the the bishop on g3 or if
Coulson doesn't push it away with f3
then I was just gonna have a super
powerful Knight here so this is what
uninsured have gone for but after Knight
captures on e5 seems across and managed
to somewhat stricken and recaptured and
now just Bishop to g3 so here of course
and keeps the bishop pair and at ease
and it is a somewhat better position
especially with so much material left on
the board his chances of winning are
immediately much higher Knights the d7
and now just h4 across and wants to open
lines he doesn't allow honor to
consolidate with g4 and of course wants
to close lines and now c5
a nice move by cross and not allowing
black to play b6 and develop this Bishop
on b7 and the idea is if you trade here
then after Bishop captures on e5 you've
basically traded your C pawn for you're
a pawn plus your rook is under attack
after the removes you're gonna lose the
c7 point and with well here with Carson
having the bishop pair and being up upon
it would be again a much better position
for him so after c5 with h5 completely
blocking of the King side and now
crossing just continues developing rook
to c1 and now c6 not allowing this point
to be pushed
further and also controlling the d5
square Knight to f6 to d5 is the idea
for Anand with Bishop to d3 by Carlsen
now comes castles by Anand and Magnus
also castles here we've looked yet now
this point will be nicely supported the
night is coming to d5 and this point is
going to be pushed to e4 and Anand will
try to create a blockade on the E and
both body and a file we're Group F 2 D 1
by Carlsen and now Knight to f6 going
after his plan Bishop vector b1 with
Knight to d5 and now Queen to c2 and
here efore as planned and now as this
bit of no longer has any purpose here
you're not very likely to remove this
point to get some Queen h7 action and
Magnus will go a3 and transfer this
bishop over to 8u we've looked at before
now putting even more pressure on this
pawn here and here on undefended with f5
just nicely cementing that pawn on e4
with a3 preparing to develop the bishop
here oh but also starting to push the
pawns on the Queen side push up the e6
by Anand and now rook C to D 1 now
transferring the pressure over to the D
file because after B 4 a 4 and B 5 is
played you want to remove the defender
of the knight on d5 and have you know a
lot of pressure on the D file with rook
a to d8 by Anand and now push up to a to
getting this Bishop on this very nice
diagonal rook to d7 and now finally
before cross and starts pushing on the
Queen side with a 6 and now comes a four
rook ET 8 and also wants to control the
D file but now b-58 captures and b5 a
cat person B 5 and now Anand had to play
King to f7 or King to g7 just either
help out with the defense on e6 or just
get a king out of this diagonal but here
he played Knight to f6 and he allowed
cousin a very nice very nice move here
all across and infiltrates with the rook
rook to d6 and here the rook is very
nicely
defended by both the bishop and the rook
here and by the pawn on c5 and also it
goes with a net with a double attack
against the bishop on e6 so Anand first
trait with Bishop captures Queen
captures with check
Quinn blocks would have seven and now
Queen to a5 again putting a lot of
pressure on this Queen side and a lot of
pressure on the D file as well so rook
captures on d6 see characters on d6 now
across and created a past D pawn we have
Queen to d7 blocking and now just a nice
trade on c6 captures captures and now
rook the b1 now across his plan is Queen
to c7 and he wants to bring the rook
either to be 7 or even to be a 2
depending on what black plays Anand
plays rook to f8 and here Queen to c7
and now you can't trade if you trade
it's it's a very dangerous path C pawn
whatever black plays doesn't really
matter just rugby 8 as the point is
nicely protected on c7 there's there's
no way to defend this position so after
Queen c7 we have rook to f7 by Anand and
now just rook b8 check King to h7 and
here Bishop to e5 threatening to remove
the defender of the Queen just Bishop
captures on f6 is a threat and also if
the knight moves that which was played
in the game and tried 95 with an attack
on the Queen but now crossing has rook
to h8 check with King to g6 and now
Queen to b8 getting the Queen out of the
way and of course hoping to infiltrate
here with Queen to g8 we have Knight
back to f6 defending in the GA square
but now cousin has a very nice tactic so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find it the best move for white
in this position I'll give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent supporter of winning tactics
in Armageddon games and for those who
just want to enjoy the show
Bishop captures on f6 it's well it's no
quite obvious of course because after
rook captures now you get Queen g8 check
and after Queen g7
you can just put d7 and there's no
stopping this pawn anymore the queen is
pinned if you trade again you cannot
stop it as the rook would be controlling
it so here on and play King captures on
f6 and now rook to h6 check here with
King to e5 and here Magnus played Queen
to 88 check if you found all of this of
course even greater congratulations as
it was in this position and more 43 that
Anand resigned the game
whatever he does doesn't work if you
move the King just Queen before is
checkmate in 1 and if you block just
let's say Ruby 7 then rotate 7 wins King
f7 king of sex yes you do you do defend
the rook but here Y can just trade
captures captures captures captures and
of course d7 is winning there is no
stopping this pass pawn so of course
I'll install this and here after Queen
h8 check on and decided to resign and a
very nice Armageddon victory for Magnus
Carlsen with the white pieces so I don't
know it's very interesting how do how do
you how do you enjoy and this classical
event but it's also not just a classical
event but a classical Armageddon event
so I don't know it's really really just
like I said it's not the first time they
attempted this this format but I don't
know if I if if I enjoy it I will have
to go through the entire tournament and
then see if it's nice or or should I
cover both the classical and the the
Armageddon game or maybe just figure out
maybe just one of them I don't know as
this is a round one I decided to show
about the classical and Armageddon game
and I will also show one one other
perhaps game from round one tomorrow
morning before round two starts but yeah
I still have to decide what I'm very
interested how are you enjoying this
format and do you think it's an
improvement will players have you know
maybe maybe they will try harder to win
in classical time formats specials and
some players who who don't really enjoy
the cooker time formats or or it is just
you know is it just maybe we should just
consider it to be a classical event with
some bonus games being played after the
main game so really just interested in
your opinions and someone asked me do I
do I even read the comments yes I pretty
much read all the comments especially
when I wake up in the morning have some
coffee and then I then I enjoy reading
the comments so you know feel free to
share but yeah I once again that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it we're
gonna be showing one more game so we're
gonna then check out the standings I
would like to thank my silly Cara for
converge to my channel thank you a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos seriously
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the OtterBox Nova
championship and well maybe deciding on
what to do maybe if I get time during
the Norway LT box championship so thank
you all I will soon have an excellent
rest of your day